now behind us what you think
about your uniform all
right all I got to say and his
brother right here you got so
much heart bro the way you play
and all the different
things that you do props to you
bro I appreciate it man it's
been a journey for sure to get
to this point one hell of
a football game what's the
sweetest part about this way
you know just coming down to the
last drive with us and
having a ball and actually being
able to get it done being
able to get it done with the
ball might don't make it a big
play us staying together keeping
our composure and we
talked about all the time but
it's like regardless of
the situation we practiced so
hard so we can
we get moments like this that we
can keep our composure or on
the field yeah that's a lot of
waving flags and towels is
a lot of your energy but look
we're locked in we've been here
before focusone play Maxim at
this opportunity you guys
talked
about Mike Williams and get him
more involved in office talk
about what you saw today so why
we want to get him involved
that he's making through for us
throughout the year and that
what he's been able to do for us
is that is huge
and we wanted always keeping
getting involved cuz that's
what he can do I like the fact
that you're able to close this
year in the past people say that
y'all could have close
y'all were getting the tiger
games and not close now you
guys are finishing
the deal that's what is that
it's
a new year right the new year
new opportunity to prove
the fans all these people out
here that hey we got something
good
going on until we can finish
this build they look really
tired and it seemed like it was
a little warmer in here that
you sense that they were tired
out there on defense I mean
regardless if they tie or not
you know it came down to it
made some plays and you'll
stepped up and got the key from
him in
the clutch yeah you know I think
the biggest thing that
would kind of went unnoticed
maybe then going by his running
today right stuff was breaking
down
he's taking out right I like the
regular corded bad guy so
we consider that guy keep it g i
noticed watch you guys on tape
is that offensive line and
Roshon Slater Import Parts on
especially the throwing ball
with a right-handed quarterback
and are you protecting
the blind spot with a rookie
coming and you never
know what you're going to get
and so is that I ever saw you
know you're we got a lot of
hopes for you and he's been out
and he's going to ask you that
the high-level and say yeah we
don't even need to help him
anymore I remember a game I was
shipping and you asked me not to
trip anymore because it was
like hey I got I got
it I got it
I've got to talk to Susan this
league man congratulations on
the win percentage at 3